une sensation vertigineuse voir cette
palette de couleurs qui se dessine et en
prendre plein les yeux
surtout ici avec tous les châteaux
servant superbe volée sous les nuages
avec des oiseaux fait c'est le rêve
d'icare
vu d'en haut le temps semble figé la
nature révèle alors toute sa beauté mais
avant de prendre les airs briefing pour
tout le monde
point crucial la météo on a du vent fort
donc en effet je pense que c'est assez
intéressant de partir du côté de du
château de guédelon le vent
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
n'est pas le meilleur allié du pilote
ça complique un petit peu le vol mais
vraiment tous les jours
la méthode différente dans chaque vol là
est vraiment différent et on s'adapte à
chaque fois c'est ce qu'on peut avec les
conditions qu'on rencontre en fonction
des conditions se décident alors le
parcours à suivre sur les points de la
carte
les 160 château à photographier donc
avant lundi on prenait le 9ème c'est ça
pour kevin et nicolas cap vers le sud et
l'ouest pour mémoriser la route à
suivent ils tracent des lignes bleues
sur la carte et entre aussi les
coordonnées gps dans leur téléphone
ça nous ferons ce château en disant que
c'est déjà pas mal il ya des photos à
faire en espérant qu'elles seront une
bonne combine combien ça fait à peu près
120 km
le temps de vol ça va mettre en trois ou
quatre heures les 15 pilotes rejoignent
leur planeur ils doivent maintenant les
emmener en bout de piste à la main une
voiture on accroche au plein air
derrière kevin n'est plus un jeune
pousse du pilotage déjà plus de dix
années passées a plané avant chaque
décollage il passe plusieurs minutes à
tout inspecter les ailes et l'extérieur
du planeur mais aussi l'intérieur du
poste de pilotage des moteurs
c'est plus simple au niveau des
commandes par contre c'est à dire qui va
nous permettre
il ya des pédales aussi voilà en
combinant un petit peu ballot manche et
les palonnier ça nous permet de nous
orienter de faire des virages d'aller à
droite à gauche comme on le souhaite
un peu plus loin un vieux planeur prend
place sur la ligne de départ
il date de 1938 pas de matériaux
composites pour celui ci mais une
composition en bois et en toile
les planeurs de bois et toile c'est
vraiment les planeurs d'ancienne
génération avant 1970 ce à partir de
1970 les premiers planeur composite qui
sont apparues et donc là en fait les
bois et toiles ont été vite dépassé
parce que matériau composite permet
d'avoir des états de surface beaucoup
plus propre ni des meilleures
performances jeunes ou anciens chaque
planeur trouve donc sa place dans la
course b sans château après les
vérifications techniques chaque pilote
enfile un parachute avant de rejoindre
la piste de départ pour l'aider à
décoller chaque planeur rétracter à 500
mètres d'altitude le planeur libère ses
ailes les courants d'air lui permettront
d'atteindre jusqu'à 2000 mètres
le pilote n'aura alors plus qu'à
contempler le paysage qui s'offre à lui
et un photographe et les châteaux tant
convoité
[Musique]